on his show last night tucker carlson
made
uh a shocking statement i call it
shocking
shocking at least if you're utterly
oblivious and naive
uh but either way this is this is what
he said
the war on terror now ongoing for 20
years has pivoted in its aims
the war on terror is now being waged
against american citizens opponents of
the regime
we saw this on display on january 6. we
told you a couple of weeks ago based on
language and publicly available
indictments
that the fbi clearly had foreknowledge
of the riot at the capitol that day
and the agents we spoke to this weekend
confirmed that is true
quote the fbi had sources in that crowd
confidential sources
snitches that's 100 percent certain
but it's not just political protesters
the government is spying on yesterday we
heard from a whistleblower within the us
government
who reached out to warn us that the nsa
the national security agency
is monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them in an attempt to take the show off
the air
now that's a shocking claim and
ordinarily we'd be skeptical of it is
illegal for the nsa to spy on american
citizens it's a crime
it's not a third world country things
like that should not happen in america
but unfortunately they do happen and in
this case they did happen
the whistleblower who is in a position
to know
repeated back to us information about a
story that we are working on
that could have only come directly from
my texts
and emails there's no other possible
source for that information
period the nsa captured that information
without our knowledge and did it for
political reasons
the biden administration is spying on us
we have confirmed that
now the uh so i i think
what you hear there are going to be two
strategies um from the left and
responding to these claims
there already has been and it's really
one and then the other
um the first is to just deny it
and and say there's no way this is true
our intelligence agencies would never do
such a thing
these are benevolent our intelligence
agencies are benevolent and kind
even though we know that the nsa spies
on american citizens that's been
confirmed we already know that they
would never do that this is absurd
even some so-called conservatives jonah
goldberg among
among them came out immediately after
this segment herod and say
no way didn't happen can't be true not
the nsa i know
come on i've known this nsa
these are this this is these are good
people they would never do such a thing
uh so that's the first strategy is just
to is to accused tucker carlson of
what making this up this whole story
making it up out of thin air
but then when um
more evidence is presented that even
they can't deny
they're going to immediately switch
course and say uh okay they're spying on
him but
uh but i'm glad they are because he's a
terrorist
you're kind of seeing a little bit of
both right now
doing the whole thing that this isn't
true but even if it was
uh it would be fine
but you'll see the
stark changing course eventually when it
becomes undeniable this is actually
happening did happen
that's when they'll say yeah i'm glad it
did
and the left is moving to that more and
more
of um
embracing these a display of power like
this
this is one of the reasons why as we
always talk about you know
pointing out the the hypocrisy of the
left
doesn't really accomplish much because
the hypocrisy is the point
it's all about it's all about cult it's
all about power
and they have the power in the culture
so they're allowed to have one standard
for themselves and another standard for
you and when you point out the hypocrisy
their answer in so many words is yeah
thanks for noticing you're right that's
exactly right
we're in control you aren't
do we said because we said so do as we
say not as we do
you know it's a power move
and eventually you'll see the same thing
with this kind of thing
yeah you're damn right
you get up there saying things we don't
like night after night you have the gall
to do that
you're the most successful cable news
show
on tv by a mile
[Music]
that's we can't allow that to happen
we're going to use all the tools at our
disposal to take you down
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content